weiter viele infektionen in immer mehr
städten gelten nächtliche
ausgangssperren einzelhandel in not das
weihnachtsgeschäft den fußgängerzonen
läuft bislang schleppend viele kunden
bleiben weg parlamentswahl in venezuela
präsident maduro lässt abstimmen die
opposition ruft zum boykott einen weg
aus der krise ist nicht in sicht
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten heute mit
samstags sport den ein wenig später
norbert lehmann präsentiert ein wunder
vor rund fünf wochen sind kontakte und
ausgehmöglichkeiten nun eingeschränkt
ohne dass sich viel getan hätte immer
noch stecken sich täglich viel zu viele
am corona virus an
nur die aussicht auf den impfstoff kann
da optimistisch stimmen
für bundeskanzlerin merkel das licht am
ende des tunnels besonders viel geduld
wird seit gestern den mannheimern
abverlangt tobias häfner zeigt warum
mannheim soll nachts still und einsam
sein um die korona fallzahlen zu senken
von 21 bis 5 uhr heißt es zu hause
bleiben ausnahmen nur für triftige
gründe wie den arbeitsweg viele ziehen
mit einigen nicht
ich bin
fakt ist die fallzahlen bleiben
bundesweit hoch das robert koch institut
meldet 23.300 18 neue infektionen
innerhalb von 24 stunden 1600 mehr als
vor einer woche
483 weitere menschen starben
digitale informierten heute
gesundheitsminister und experten über
den stand beim großprojekt corona
impfung der tenor die zulassung ist auf
gutem weg und spätestens nach dem
jahreswechsel stellt sich die große
frage wer bekommt die impfstoffe wacker
chef wiler sagte er wäre gerne einer der
ersten wisse aber dass er und viele
andere einfach warten müssten damit muss
ich leben und ich muss mich dann eben
vielleicht noch länger schützen als
andere aber diese diese solidarische
bewertung in unserer gesellschaft dass
man diesen gruppen nach bestimmten
wissenschaftlich fundierten gründen denn
ein früher und die andere später impft
das müssen wir aushalten geimpft werden
soll bis auf weiteres nur in den
geplanten impfzentren und nicht in
arztpraxen weil die extrem kalte
lagerung überall gewährleistet werden
soll aber auch aus sicherheitsgründen
es wird ja nicht umsonst an konzepten
gearbeitet bis hin zum polizeilichen
schutz der impfzentren weil weil das
natürlich schon auch mit emotionen
kommen kann da wenn jemand sagt ich will
jetzt aber fällt aber noch nicht unter
denjenigen die dran sind dann weiß ich
nicht ob hausärzte wirklich wollen dass
das alles bei ihnen in der praxis
stattfindet ernst mal heißt es aber
dezember fallzahlen sinken in mannheim
wurde erst mal ermahnt doch bald drohen
bußgelder
mehrere impfstoffe stehen kurz vor der
zulassung wie gut schützen sie in
unserer zdf heute app finden sie
antworten zur wirkungen und
nebenwirkungen zum durchklicken
die pandemie hat den einzelhandel kalt
erwischt das so wichtige
weihnachtsgeschäft läuft schleppend
viele kunden und kundinnen bleiben weg
wegen corona gekauft wird online auch
die schärferen maßnahmen setzen im
einzelhandel zu seit dem ersten dezember
gilt in kleineren und mittelgroßen läden
darf sich ein kunde
den quadratmeter aufhalten für größere
geschäfte etwa kaufhäuser ist die regeln
noch strenger ein kunde pro 20
quadratmeter dominik müller rosell war
in köln unterwegs
es ist was los bei globetrotter in köln
aber schlange stehen um hereingelassen
zu werden das muss dann heute doch
niemand rund 6000 quadratmeter
verkaufsfläche haben sie das heißt 360
kunden dürfen sich gleichzeitig im laden
aufhalten
an diesem zweiten adventssamstag liegen
sie jederzeit darunter ernüchterung
wir dürfen zwar öffnen aber die kunden
sind nicht mehr da weil man natürlich
berechtigterweise gesagt hat bleibt zu
hause
letztendlich auch zu hause ist der
schutz am besten und die match befolgen
sie kommen nicht mehr an die stadt die
frequenzen und nur 15 prozent
zurückgegangen
auch heute deutlich weniger los als
sonst an einem adventswochenende wie
hier in köln nur vereinzelt schlangen
vor einem geschäft besser schnell rein
und wieder raus stadt bummeln und sich
treiben lassen zu wissen wo sich um 10
uhr u15 waren wir hier und weil wir
exakt los wollte man bewusst dass nicht
so viel los ist und dann können wir
nachher auch schneller weg vor allem
kaufhäuser und modeketten leiden und
jetzt zeichnet sich ab
das weihnachtsgeschäft wird die lage
nicht retten die frequenzen sind im
november schon um bis zu 60 prozent
zurückgegangen die umsätze 40 bis 50
prozent unter dem vorjahr und das gerade
für branchen die natürlich im
weihnachtsgeschäft bis zu 25 prozent
ihres jahresumsatzes machen insofern
haben wir hier eine sehr schwierige
situation nur wenige schlangen heute
stattdessen viel platz für den
einzelhandel geht ein hartes jahr hart
zu ende
auch griechenland kämpft gerade mit der
zweiten corona welle bemerkenswert weil
die erste dort kaum messbar war kein
anderes land in europa war zunächst so
gut durch die krise gekommen
doch dann schossen die zahlen im oktober
hoch daher gilt seit november ein
strenger lockdown der jetzt noch einmal
verlängert wurde
denn die krankenhäuser sind am limit
andreas postel
seit dem landesweiten lockdown liegt die
akropolis einsam und verlassen da corona
zwingt griechenland erneut in den
ruhezustand museen restaurants und
geschäfte geschlossen nur apotheken
lebensmittelläden und tankstellen
bleiben offen eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre gilt ab 21 uhr
die situation ist sehr belastend weil
wir jetzt zum zweiten mal einer lock
down erleben
finanziell wird es sehr schwierig die
feiertage kommen und wir sind
eingeschlossen und von den menschen
isoliert iw lieben 300 euro strafe muss
zahlen wer gegen die strengen ausgangs
beschränkungen verstößt die wohnung darf
nur mit einer sondergenehmigung
verlassen werden das tragen von mund
nasen schutz ist überall verpflichten
okay das ist nicht das schönste nicht
das angenehmste aber immerhin trägt es
hoffentlich dazu bei dass wir griechen
vorsichtiger sind geschützt und das
scheint auch nötig in der
einsatzzentrale des griechischen
zivilschutzes registrieren sie besonders
in nordgriechenland alarmierende taten
über 600 infektionsfälle auf 100000
einwohner
natürlich haben wir ein problem
schließlich haben wir eine große
ausbreitung in der bevölkerung und auch
unser gesundheitssystem ist ganz
besonders unter druck in den
krankenhäusern und intensivstationen
ganz nord griechenland ist belastungs
zone rot das griechische fernsehen zeigt
aufnahmen aus thessaloniki ein friedhof
auf dem eilig neue gräber ausgehoben
werden und eine beerdigung wenn er nur
zwei angehörige anwesend sind
das griechische gesundheitswesen ist
auch durch den sparkurs nach der
euro-krise in einem kritischen zustand
es fehlt an ärzten und pflegepersonal
momentan scheint sich die lage zwar
etwas zu stabilisieren der strenge
lockten aber gilt in griechenland
vorerst bis zum 14 dezember bei der
regierungskrise in sachsen anhalt geht
es im kern um die frage soll der landtag
der geplanten erhöhung des
rundfunkbeitrags um 86 cent zustimmen
oder nicht die cdu ist dagegen und käme
gemeinsam mit der afg auf eine mehrheit
jetzt hat der sächsische cdu
ministerpräsident kretschmann seine
parteikollegen ermahnt es sei kein gutes
signal wenn der staatsvertrag scheitern
würde jeder einzelne abgeordnete habe
eine staatsbürgerliche verantwortung
das sagte er dem redaktions netzwerk
deutschland dreieinhalb jahre sind die
hamburger krawalle rund um den
g20-gipfel jetzt her
vorgestern begann ein prozess gegen fünf
der randalierer
für heute hatten deshalb linke gruppen
zum protest aufgerufen darunter mehrere
die vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet
werden von rund 2.000 demonstrierenden
spricht die polizei
bislang blieb alles friedlich die fünf
angeklagten sollen damals in einer
gruppe mit gelaufen sein
aus der heraus polizisten mit steinen
beworfen wurden und nun zu einem thema
für das langsam die zeit knapp wird den
br- exit es bleiben noch drei wochen
dann droht ein austritt ohne abkommen
und deshalb ist es heute chefsache
am abend telefonierte der britische
premierminister johnson und
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
miteinander
dabei dürfte es um drei knackpunkte
gehen staatshilfen die den wettbewerb
nicht verzerren dürfen die frage der
streitschlichtung falls sich eine seite
nicht an das abkommen hält und ob eu
fischer in britischen gewässern fischen
dürfen
dazu fragen an anne gellinek in brüssel
das gespräch ist vorbei was ist dann
herausgekommen an
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen hat gerade eine erklärung
abgegeben eine sehr kurze erklärung in
der sie sagte dass die verhandlungen
weiterhin sehr sehr schwierig sein man
es aber trotzdem noch einmal mit einem
letzten putschversuchen wollen ab morgen
sollen die verhandlungen hier in brüssel
weiter gehen die briten hatten erst
gestern bei den verhandlungen beim thema
wettbewerbsrecht neue dinge auf den
tisch gelegt die eigentlich schon längst
besprochen als besprochen galten das
wertete man hier in brüssel als zeichen
dass die londoner seite noch einmal den
druck auf die verhandlungen erhöhen
jetzt also lautet die antwort auf die
frage will johnson wirklich verhandeln
erstmal ja aber es bleibt bei all den
drei themen die oft die noch zu
verhandeln sind äußerst schwierig sowohl
bei den fischerei rechten als auch beim
zugang der briten zum eu binnenmarkt als
auch bei der frage wie man das
vereinbarte wenn denn etwas vereinbart
wird kontrollieren will also die gute
nachricht wenn man so will ist ab morgen
wird wieder geredet am montagabend
wollen von der leyen & johnson noch
einmal telefonieren ob das dann zu einem
abkommen führt ist heute abend weiter
offen
ja und damit zu diana zimmermann in
london
johnson steht ja ziemlich unter druck
sprich das denn er für seine
kompromissfähigkeit oder dagegen
also für einen deal spricht ganz klar
dass boris johnson einen versprochen hat
und dass beide seiten vor allem aber
großbritannien unter no deal wirklich
sehr leiden würden außerdem könnte
dieses abkommen lose dasein nicht lange
halten irgendwann müssten eu und
großbritannien wieder an den
verhandlungstisch also warum nicht jetzt
eine lösung finden
gegen den deal spricht das naturell des
premiers der markt kompromisse nicht und
betrachtet sie als niederlagen
hier war es von anfang an so dass die
erwartungen an dieses abkommen viel zu
hoch geschraubt wurden es wurde getönt
dass sei der einfachste dir der
geschichte und großbritannien werde
weiterhin vollen zugang zum binnenmarkt
haben und dazu alle freiheiten genießen
das ist natürlich nicht so wie wir an
diesen zellen und mühsamen verhandlungen
sehen und boris johnson hat das problem
dass er diesen sehr dünnen dir den das
nur noch geben kann jetzt irgendwie
triumphal verkaufen können muss dazu
bräuchte er ein zugeständnis der eu und
das hat er heute abend noch nicht vielen
dank nach london und nach brüssel in
venezuela wird morgen ein neues
parlament gewählt unter denkbar
schwierigen vorzeichen wirtschaftskrise
armut und die korona pandemie haben das
land fest im griff
dazu kommt der machtkampf zwischen
staatspräsident maduro und
oppositionsführer guido der hatte sich
im januar 2019 selbst zum
interims-präsidenten erklärt viele
länder erkannten ihn als staatschef an
auch die usa und deutschland
nun ruft er zum boykott der wahl
auf christoph rath berichtet im kleinen
kann so libere welt noch selbst
gestalten die weihnachtsdekoration ist
für viele venezolaner die letzte
bescheidene extravaganz die sie sich
leisten
ansonsten hat sie den glauben verloren
die einstige sozialistin weiß nicht
einmal wie sie das traditionelle
weihnachtsessen zu bereiten soll
es ist schwierig die einzelnen zutaten
zusammen zu bekommen deshalb müssen wir
es aufteilen und tauchte erst eine zutat
und dann eine andere dass man alles
komplett das einkaufen ist eine tägliche
frustration so liebert hat angst mit uns
zu sprechen will aber nicht länger
schweigen
die parlamentswahl sei eine farce weil
die opposition kaum eine chance habe
dennoch wird sie wählen gehen
eine regierung die lange an der macht
bleibt verliert ihre grenzen und wenn
wir unsere grenzen verlieren glauben dir
so sehr an das was wir tun dass wir
unsere fehler nicht mehr erkennen
staatschef maduro sieht die chance die
opposition kleinzukriegen im parlament
dem einzigen international als
demokratisch anerkannten organ venezuela
dazu hat er die wahlkommission mit
getreuen besetzt wahlbezirke passend
zurecht schneiden lassen
unabhängige beobachter gibt es keine ich
vertraue aufs volk sagt der präsident
siegessicher aus protest boykottieren
die wichtigsten kräfte der opposition
die wahl
allen voran der selbst ernannte
interimspräsident motto es ist möglich
eine machtübergabe in venezuela zu
erreichen freie wahlen zu fordern nicht
den betrug der diktatur
das tun wir auch wenn es riskant ist das
risiko für guardado ist groß
international anerkannt kann er sich im
inland nicht durchsetzen wenn er nun
auch sein amt als parlamentspräsident
verliert könnte es noch schwerer werden
staatschef maduro eines tages abzulösen
jetzt zu einer mit spannung erwarteten
rückkehr aus dem all
seit sechs jahren ist die japanische
raumsonde hayabusa 2 im all unterwegs
ein teil dieser sonder soll in diesen
minuten zur erde zurückgekehrt sein
eine 40 cm kleine kapsel mit an bord
gesteinsproben eines asteroiden
4,6 milliarden jahre alt sie sollen
aufschluss über den ursprung unseres
sonnensystems liefern die sonde hayabusa
zwei selbst bleibt im all für weitere
forschungsmissionen ja und nun zu dir
norbert und zur fußball-bundesliga hat
borussia dortmund bei der
verfolgungsjagd auf spitzenreiter bayern
münchen zum zweiten mal in folge punkte
liegen lassen
nur ein unentschieden gegen die
eintracht hier die bisherigen ergebnisse
des zehnten spieltages frankfurt gegen
dortmund 1 2 1 freiburg gegen gladbach 2
zu 2
köln gegen wolfsburg ebenfalls 2 2 im
kellerduell gewinnt wieder fällt knapp
gegen mainz mit 221 das abendspiel ja
das ist ein echtes topspiel der tabellen
erste bayern gegen den zweiten leipzig
und bereits gestern besiegte im
hauptstadt-derby härter union berlin mit
3 zu 1 die tabelle ganz oben bislang
alles unverändert dortmund macht einen
platz gut und ist jetzt dritter vor
bayer leverkusen das aber morgen wieder
am bvb vorbeiziehen kann
dahinter wolfsburg union und gladbach
die zweite tabellenhälfte beginnt mit
stuttgart und am tabellenende haben
bielefeld und mainz die plätze getauscht
schlusslicht ist schalke ja und das
topspiel bayern gegen leipzig
ausführlich bei uns im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23 uhr 30
skisprung-weltcup in nischni tagil heute
ohne vize weltmeister karl geiger der
wird vater aber mit markus eigenbrötler
der steht nach seinem ersten sprung vor
seinem dritten saisonsieg ja und dann
das große pech die enttäuschung war
markus eisenbichler ins gesicht
geschrieben nach deutlicher führung im
ersten durchgang scheint der sieg fast
nur formsache
doch dann erwischte ihn beim zweiten
sprung eine windböe die alle chancen
zunichte macht den absprung erwischt er
noch perfekt aber dann gerät er aus dem
gleichgewicht und kann einen sturz
gerade noch verhindern
platz 28 am ende für den bayer von
dessen missgeschick der norweger halvard
kann erhöht als sieger profitiert
bester deutscher ist damit pius paschke
als fünfter biathlon weltcup in
kontiolahti ein starker fünfter platz
für benedikt doll in der verfolgung und
die frauen-staffel stürmt sogar aufs
podest dank einer hervorragenden denise
herrmann als denise herrmann als letzte
der vier frauen in die spur geht sind es
fast zwölf sekunden die deutsche
mannschaft von einem podestplatz
entfernt ist
doch die 31 jährige überzeugt nicht nur
in der loipe mit gewohnter lautstärke
auch am schießstand bleibt sie ruhig
gelassen und fehlerfrei und da ist bei
schwierigen windbedingungen im
finnischen kontiolahti von platz vier
auf drei am ende das im ersten rennen
des winters über 4 x 6 kilometer
die staffel gewinnen können die
favoritinnen aus schweden vor frankreich
und deutschland und morgen kämpfen die
frauen in der verfolgung und die männer
in der staffel interessant dann genau
was das wetter präsentiert sich am
zweiten advent trüb und nass für einige
auch mit schnee und glätte
mehr dazu gleich von katja honnefer das
war es an diesem samstag schön dass sie
dabei waren
das heute journal mit claus kleber heute
erst um 23 uhr 15
wir sehen uns hoffentlich morgen wieder
punkt 7 einen angenehmen abend wünschen
wird
[Musik]
knaben meine damen und herren das thema
dieses zweiten adventswochenendes ist
eindeutig der schnee in den südalpen
auch in den nächsten 24 stunden wird es
in österreich in oberitalien aber auch
in vielen teilen der schweiz kräftig
weiter schneien
da können noch mal so 50 60 cm neuschnee
zusammenkommen
auch bei uns in deutschland fällt schnee
und regen dieses regen und schnee band
liegt heute abend zwischen dem thüringer
wald und dem bodensee und es zieht im
laufe der nacht weiter nach westen und
dann klettert das ein bisschen
auseinander und dieser nördliche dieser
regen teil der verlässt deutschland
morgen nordwärts und dann beginnt es vom
schwarzwald er wieder zu schneien
weiter richtung norden ist es aber auch
regen heute nacht machen sie sich also
auf gefährlich glatte straßen gefasst
zwischen den mittelgebirgen und am
alpenrand dem osten ist es häufig klar
im westen bildet sich auch mal nebel und
die temperaturen sinken auf plus fünf
bis minus 3 grad morgen liegen sie dann
am alpenrand nur bei 0 grad aber
deutlich milder wird sich in der lausitz
mit zwölf grad und das liegt am
südostwind der rub die wolken
auseinander da kommt dann auch mal die
sonne zum vorschein
am montag zum berufsverkehr kann es im
westen sehr gefährlich stadt seien auf
den straßen danach beruhigt sich das
wetter schön haben nach